all making terrible admission to you
one of the most difficult aspects of
becoming an editor was trying to
understand other writers and help them
encourage them push them all the same
and to discover that more writers than I
would have imagined it may be I think
they're being honest protested they hate
writing they don't like writing it's
it's painful it's all those things that
you've you've heard I didn't realize it
ran as deep or as wide a terrible
confession I mean maybe it speaks to the
banality of my own writing with the
limitations of my own writing I actually
love to do it I think there are probably
musicians that love to rehearse and sit
at the piano or and then there are ones
that really like to have recorded and
like to have played and liked to do
almost anything else but it's especially
true with writing
I find it the stimulation and the
getting it wrong and the getting it
wrong and the finally figuring out what
it is you think or the process of making
a story out of reality that actually is
true enormous ly endlessly exciting and
so I I love doing it there I I guess
there are there are again I'm just a
journalist but there are sculptors
that's just like having their hand in
the clay all the time and a word for
that we're writing might be concerned as
a graphic maniac but I certainly in
recent years I can't be accused of
writing too much
no I just get bad writing writer's block
means nothing comes out I haven't had
that experience in any serious way I've
had endless frustration I've filled
garbage cans or where now you know bins
on your little desktop but I don't mind
this the zips flush necessary for
writing the sort of Asuna chair
concentrated time in fact I I relish it